ten years ago the know your stats
campaign was born and the reason why it
is so important is because June being
mental Men's Health Awareness Month
prostate cancer awareness through the
American neurological associations know
your stats campaign is crucially
important and the man to my right is
physical proof of that ten years ago he
was diagnosed with prostate cancer and
you look great
my pains good to see you Pro Football
Hall of Famer Mike Haynes yeah thank you
you know I always enjoy being seen ID
being here rather than being I guess
seen in that respect I've heard that
joke before so it was ten years ago you
got the news how old are you right now
64 so at 54 you go to the doctor and you
get this news is that well not actually
you know went to a screening at the Pro
Football Hall of Fame and um at the time
actually worked at the NFL and so they
asked me to go take a look and see how
the screening is going so I go over and
these two ladies cute ladies say hey why
don't you participate maybe encourage
some of the other guys to do it I said
all right stop all I know is a simple
blood test well there's another part of
the test that I didn't know about it's
called the digital rectal exam and so um
before I had the digital rectal exam the
doctor called me in said hey just cancer
around your family I said I don't know
my grandfather died of some kind of
cancer but I don't know and he's and he
said that one in nine men will be
diagnosed with prostate cancer in their
lifetime and african-americans are more
likely to get the disease in the general
public and if it runs in your family
it's even more guys are gonna get it so
he gave me enough information that when
I got home I called my primary care
doctor and had a conversation hmm and I
left out an important part of that story
when he called me and he also gave him
the digital rectal exam that's why
that's the other part of the test that
you have to do and so when I got back
home call my primary care doctor he
looked at my chart gave my new
information as well you know I think
you're fine Mike but since you're
african-american let's get you a biopsy
because that's the only way you can tell
for sure not gonna ever find out at a
screening only thing you can find out as
a screen that something may be going on
with your prostate
well my by ops
she came back positive I had cancer in
nine of the 12 places that ninja yeah so
what are the stats that you need to know
base well I tell you the most important
stat you need to know is if the cancer
runs in your family prostate cancer
because if it does you want to have a
conversation with your doctor early on
maybe in your early 40s I know guys I've
even started earlier than that but if it
doesn't run in your family you can wait
to your mid-50s
most men are gonna die with prostate
cancer in their body guaranteed you have
it in your body right now but your body
is tolerating it is it's managing it and
you have to be aware of what's going on
so if those numbers get a whack where
something needs to be done you want to
know about it in the early stages when
it's easily treatable and I found out by
luck by being the right place having
this conversation with the doctor and I
don't want men to find out the way I did
I want to be a little bit more proactive
and looking for something like that does
that's really what our campaign is about
know your stats org to find out and more
information and I'll just give some
right here
one in five you change your having
prostate cancers one in five if you have
a family history so that's 20% right
yeah one in six if you're
african-american and then one in nine
for those who fall into neither category
yeah so know your stats and get get
checked out my canes here on the Rich
Eisen show Pro Football Hall of Famer I
turn to you and ask you what how the
news of Terrell Owens saying I'm not
coming from my induction ceremony hit
you and and others that you might have
been speaking to about this well you
know it hit me like a ton of bricks
really like I'm shocked it is the
greatest honor that t/o can receive as a
football player and it's the greatest
honor I've ever received and everybody
feels the same way and I remember the
day that I met a lot of those guys knit
ski and Deacon Jones and they're there
telling me Mike you've just joined a
team that you can never be cut from you
can't even die off of this team and I
started to at that point start to
realize what was actually going on this
with it was not just another big sports
banquet you know this is the greatest
honor you're gonna ever have so when I
heard about tío I thought there's got to
be something going on I don't know
there's gotta be more than this to the
story I don't have all the information
because this is not something you want a
guy like tio to regret this isn't one of
greatest moments and he'll be talking
about this like come on I was inducted
in 97 and I'm still proud to wear this
jacket I'm still when I'm introduced as
a Hall of Famer it still means a lot to
me NAND means a lot to football fans and
people in this country how long did it
take you to get in four years um well
I've got in on my third time and so like
TF so if it's that's if that's it just
like Co by the way yeah if that is the
deal then then I can't understand how he
feels but I don't remember it anymore
and I was voted to the end of the
all-time NFL team first team so
everybody said oh you're a first-ballot
hall-of-famer and so I wasn't so then
the next year I said well I guess they
made a mistake
matter of fact that first year Joe
Horgan actually called me no no no like
I said we want you to be back in your
hotel next to the phone it's not like
today obviously so the phone rings he
goes hey Mike it's Joe Horgan Pro
Football Hall of Fame and then someone
must have said something to him he goes
what oh oh oh
he hangs up oh wow so I sit there
waiting for the phone to ring again it
never rings so I go back to my meeting
and everybody in the meeting is aware
that I wasn't inducted because they had
given the list of the guys who had made
it and where I was I couldn't see that
and so um I do want to just enter just a
wild in in the middle of the story just
a Joe Horgan Pro Football Hall of Fame
he's been there forever and he has his
job for many years to call up those to
say that you're in I just may be
sweetest guy on planet Earth yes so I
know you're telling your story for
perspective right to make sure that
you're you're not throwing I appreciate
that I just want to make sure that
because I know you and I know Joe and I
just want to people might perceive that
but all that said I mean what message
would you give to Tootie oh I can sort
of figure it out what you're saying but
I just you know yeah put it out there
and no messages whatever if you if
there's an issue you know unless let's
get it out there because we can maybe we
can help solve this problem if it's of
not being a first-ballot guy take a
number how many guys think they should
have been on
first time and they didn't work out that
way including myself who was an all-time
NFL first team player and didn't make it
all right take a number
I also don't have a vote so if there's a
bunch of Hall of Famers that you don't
like or whatever I don't have a vote and
if I did you'd have been in you're gonna
be in I've always said that you're gonna
be in sooner or later don't worry about
it but the Hall of Famers don't have a
vote the the people at the Hall of Fame
don't have a vote the people in Canton
Ohio don't have a vote you know and all
three groups absolutely want to be with
you on that day it is gonna be the
greatest day in your life I think and
I'd hate to see him regret you know not
being part of that celebration Mike
Haynes here on the on the Rich Eisen
show your Super Bowl championship season
Super Bowl 18 I mean you know weird
Super Bowl 53 that's amazing
that was the famed Marcus Allen
pirouette right in the Raiders beating
the Redskins and by the way that was a
1983 season next time that the that the
AFC won the Super Bowl was Super Bowl
xxxii well yeah Broncos once it was a it
was quite a long drought for the AFC
what was your perspective on that run
did you see it live were you in a
defensive huddle or something no I was
on the sideline and I was just I could
not believe what I really couldn't
believe is after that run he just walks
away he doesn't put his hands on his
hips and put the ball down and huff and
puff
he just ran like a hundred it looked
like 150 yards you know and he just gave
the ball away and and started walking
back to the our sideline like wow I'm I
remember running out to the field and
kaneo to congratulate him like a lot of
other players but one of the greatest
plays I've ever been around who was the
toughest guy for you to defend like to
be honest they were all tough and is not
the honesty I'm looking for well I'll be
very very happy I'm being honest with
you well when I say that because I've
actually put my guard down a couple of
times and I really gotten embarrass he
ever heard a guy named Guido merkins I
do not know I think he was a third
string quarterback for the New Orleans
Saints he beat me for a touchdown in the
LA Coliseum
absolutely I'll never forget it I'll
never forget it and why is because we
were beating the New Orleans Saints so
bad I kept looking in the sidelines on
Willie and Willie Brown was our
secondary coach and so Willie take us
out take me out yeah you know why am I
still in the game because I'll just stay
in a few more plays
then here comes Geeta merkins into the
game lüt oh gosh no now they're bringing
these guys in he beat me for a touchdown
and so there's a message there really
it's like if you're in the National
Football League if there's a player in
the National Football League he is there
because he can get the job done if if
Guiteau Marquez is out there running
pass routes it's not to kill time that
guy can catch and he can run and he
deserves to be out there doing that and
so they all gave me fits and I prepared
for each one of them like they were the
best to ever play the game course I
didn't study for Guiteau didn't even
know if he'd be playing but the guy who
proudly gave me the most hardest time
I'd have to say is Harold Carmichael
just because of his height he's - he was
just yeah he was a big red X 8 and you
know there's nothing you can do the ball
is up in the air who's gonna out jump
who come on 5050 yeah they're funny only
chance I have is knocking it out of his
hand as he's bringing it down right and
then you know when it all when it all
comes down to it Mike just so you know
you you will want to I believe it's
Guido merkins you're one of his 3 career
touchdowns
[Laughter]
you gave him a cookie and I have to ask
yeah we still talked about him well you
also talked about from that day to is
the famed Lester Hayes yeah come did ya
did you never I didn't have to stick
them no I didn't have to what a lot of
people don't know about Lester's he was
alignment as a youth football player
mm-hmm you know and I was in college he
was a linebacker and so he never really
was in a position where they're used to
touching the ball but when he came to
the Raiders and no the he was able to
make plays but he wasn't able to catch
the ball and Freddie Biletnikoff he used
to use a little stick and bury you know
gingerly you know he's have a little
pocket on the side that he would make
with tape and put the stick him in there
and whenever you finish sock uh yeah he
had a tape special tape job on his sock
and they put a little pocket in there he
put the stick him in there and he he
reach down and touch it and then he used
it on his hands like
so it's just on his fingertips yeah that
wasn't enough for Lester
you know let's ever go to the jar you
can just put it all over himself and I
think they even have a picture of him
catching uh making an interception with
a ball stick to the back of his hand he
also has a shot of him like pulling his
hand up like he looks like Freddy
Krueger like the a marine like a steed
it looks like he's got knives coming at
the top of his phone but an incredible
player an incredible player and after
playing the Patriots for seven years and
then go into the Raiders and making Pro
Bowl six out of seven years yes sir you
would think I had nothing else to learn
I got to the Raiders I had plenty to
learn and it was really great having
Lester on my team because he was a real
student of the game and we sit there and
look at film I learned so much from him
you know because he was a youth football
player he looked at the game a little
bit differently from me because he had
so many more years of football under him
you know and then with Willie Brown and
the bump and run technique and I learned
a lot from him so last thing for you on
your jacket what's the number in your
jacket because it's every single person
gets number 186 you have 186 yeah you
were enshrining 186 yeah that's again
just your tio is gonna be in Trani 300
or what have you it's Gabby and that's
inside a jacket forever nobody literally
can take that away no one can take that
away come on tio and so so you know you
there's a couple things I'm gonna do I'm
gonna do some homework and I actually
I'm here in LA I'm hoping I get a chance
to talk to you while I'm here because
maybe the NFL needs to change the way we
do our parties for the Hall of Famers
you know instead of it being something
that the player does maybe it's
something that the league does and then
and they divide that by 32 owners the
cost of whatever that part is it's
nothing and it maybe we shouldn't be um
you know guys not wanting to come
because of the financial burden that it
might cost again he has not stated a
specific reason as to why other than the
fact that he went to Canton he heard the
mission statement and said after hearing
that he just wants to do this as opposed
to what everybody else before him has
done or is expected of anybody else who
is in
or selected for that I honestly don't
know but I'm more than happy to reach
out and maybe hope yeah you guys up I
love that that'd be great rich at my
Cannes NFL on Twitter again no your
stats org your life or the life of a
loved one depends on it potentially good
to see you love thank you here thank you
man the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience